[Music]
it was a paranoid anxiety of like I
don't want any Rick and Morty fan
hearing that and going like Harmons on
on smith's podcast and he's talking
about how it's great how you can take as
much time off as he wants the reason why
the reason why we're not working about
right good morning right now ain't
because i figured out that i don't need
to impress you it's still something
called contract negotiations and it's
gotten complicated this is tamara in
success brick and mortars in limbo I
didn't see the headlines it's not in
limbo it's there's a negotiable
negotiating a contract and I still
negotiating I said to the 5,000th kid
that tweeted me hey you fat lazy
alcoholics stopped being so slow writing
the scripts like cuz they're 15 and they
I understand that they don't know how TV
works I just don't understand why
they're so horrible why are they so mean
why are they so there's no you can't
when when community fans would go I'm
upset right now because Annie kissed
Jeff instead of Britta I would go first
of all you're you're crazy because
you're upset with me and they're
fictional characters but second of all
that's how I feel about TV - thank you
for the biggest compliment in the world
which is total immersion in my narrative
and I get it I understand the the
compliment on this I get it these kids
that are like like they ate a cupcake
today and they're like why don't you
stop eating cupcakes and write the show
you piece of and it's like we
skipped the part where you like it even
like it's crazy clearly you do it was
there a world where that would work like
oh will you stop eating cupcakes and
you'd write the script and you read no
it's just writing the show even though
it hasn't been ordered by the network
which is why now the trades because now
I held at a 15 year old like it hasn't
been ordered and then so now it's like I
just I can see on this the Absolut Vodka
sponsored side bars of like Vicks
websites where I'm trying to
like procrastinate see like my name and
I see Rick and Morty thumbnails oh my
god you did it again
and but but like yeah is there a
universe where a kids saying that would
make me write a season of Rick and Morty
by myself without getting together with
Justin it was just adjusting I'm just
you know what this is taking so long I'm
gonna just start writing the show cuz
you're gonna have to write it anyway
right exactly the change it was still a
head start faded Rick's like I love
inventing stuff and it's like like
lately
ya know I don't I don't see if there was
a world where that was going to happen I
think maybe the kid would be saying
something along the lines of I have Lou
Gehrig's disease and I'd love to see a
script of Rick and Morty before I die
and obviously that's not good I'm not
gonna get to see the show
maybe not hey you PC you're fat this is
why your wife left you like they dig
into my personal life
and like you don't know how TV works and
you don't know what this is you're 15 so
you're supposed to be dumb but you're
not supposed to have this hubris
this is dangerous I guess this is what
all old people have said about young
people forever hey everybody it's
Charlie so just another Rick and Morty
season four update since I posted in my
last video a couple days ago Dan Harmon
talked about it on his harmontown
podcast recently and I think he was
pretty clear about what exactly was
going on then Justin roiland
also separately made some comments he
just said for everyone telling me to get
back to work on Rick and Morty season
four turn your attention to Turner
talking about Turner networks who's the
parent company that owns Adult Swim
which owns Rick and Morty I'm waiting
around just like you making some cool
games in the meantime though his
squatched endo label makes a lot of
virtual reality games so if you are into
that that's actually another way to
support Justin but Dan Harmon isn't
involved in that stuff and it's separate
from the Rick and Morty stuff that they
do then Dan Harmon had the joke reply
that no matter whose side you taken this
whether you take Adult Swim or turn our
network side or Dan and Justin side it
won't really make that much of a
difference because both sides of this
understand how valuable Rick and Morty
is from a fan
standpoint in a cultural standpoint so
in that last video that I posted where
they're talking about how their
contracts are up for renewal that's
really where you get to their
disagreement like how much is it worth
to Adult Swim and how much do they want
to give to Justin and Dan for the next
season meaning that they can't work on
it till their agents lock down their
deal like it gives them less leverage if
they're already working on it because
Adult Swim can say oh look you know
you're already working on it they need
Adult Swim's lawyers to sweat at the
thought that they might not make Rick
and Morty season four meaning that
nobody would get any money and it's all
just part of the bargaining process that
goes on in Hollywood come on don't be
like that the universe is a crazy
chaotic place you're the one that's
crazy and chaotic the same exact thing
is happening in the Marvel Universe
right now with Robert Downey jr. in
Chris Evans and a couple of the other
actors from phase one and Phase two use
it the actor the producer whoever it is
the writer winds up getting a lot more
money for further material but obviously
the sole goal of the network is to be a
business entity and make more money
meaning they don't want to give them any
of their deal points so that's basically
what's been taking this long so I think
this video that I posted yesterday was
recorded back in June it was like early
June or something like that about a
month before season 3 premiered so you
have to imagine that it's taken this
long for Adult Swim and Dan Justin's
lawyers to hammer out a deal and they're
still going that's why the other person
in the podcast was like you're still
negotiating it's almost like a year
later and they're still at it
and the reason why Dan sort of joked
about working on it by himself you know
it's taking too long I'm just gonna go
ahead and start working on it is is that
that would also decrease their leverage
in the deal meaning that until paper is
signed on ink they can't touch Rick and
Morty which is why you see a lot of the
producers the animators the other
support staff from Rick and Morty moving
on to other projects just waiting for
that deal to be signed so that they can
all come back and start working on it
but the really good news in this is that
the delay has absolutely nothing to do
with creative burnout it sounds like
they're totally ready to make it and had
the deal been signed last year they
would have started immediately so the
delay is taken this long it sounds like
it's not gonna last that much
just charting the time line animation
takes about a year to complete so I
would give him about six months to write
the season and then start sending it off
to animation meaning that if Dana
Justin's lawyers an Adult Swim Turner's
lawyers come to terms before the summer
then we can see Rick and Morty season
four episodes by the end of the year
2019 which would actually sync up with
mr. poopy butthole big white Santa Claus
beard the funny thing is is now I wonder
if when they recorded that mr. poopy
butthole post-credits scene if they knew
that this deal was gonna take a long
time to hammer out because Rick and
Morty had blown up so big the ratings
for the first couple of seasons were
pretty good but season three was the
most viewed season of a TV show that
Adult Swim had ever had in the history
of their network so they also won a
couple Annie Awards so they basically
just became this big cultural force and
even the trades were reporting that Rick
and Morty season 3 was the most-watched
television show of any kind of show not
just animated shows amongst young people
meaning that there's just like a lot of
money that they stand to make if they
can hammer out a really good deal which
is why it's taking so long anytime
there's that much money involved it just
goes on and on and on no company or
corporation out there is gonna walk up
to you and say you know what we want to
give you even more money than we gave
you before so in the meantime if you do
want to support Dan and Justin then buy
the DVDs buy the merchandise they get a
cut from that the DVD is probably the
easiest way to do that and I will do a
giveaway when it drops which is
happening pretty soon but be sure to
subscribe to get all the Rick and Morty
bonus videos leave your requests in the
comments below and you can click here to
rewatch that video of them actually
talking about season four just joking
about their contract renewals and you
can click here to rewatch that Deadpool
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]